europa brennt alarmstufe rot in unseren
urlaubs regierungen temperaturen von
über 40 grad und mitten in der
hitzewelle krachen jetzt auch noch
waldbrände in boa vista in portugal
können viele menschen auf der flucht vor
dem inferno nur noch das nötigste retten
und wir sehen hier einen bauern der
eines seiner lämmer auf die schultern
genommen hat und uns so aus der
flammenhölle gerettet hat
ja in kroatien zum beispiel flüchten
auch hunderte urlauber an die strände
raus einfach nur raus aus der stadt ist
die devise in der die flammen wüten dich
darauf und auch viel nebel erschweren
die sicht und im hintergrund können wir
auch wirklich pure verzweiflungsschrei
tausende touristen und anwohner mussten
wegen dieser heftigen brände evakuiert
werden spanien portugal frankreich und
italien es brennt in den beliebtesten
urlaubsregionen von uns deutschen eine
besserung der lage ist nicht in sicht
ganz im gegenteil dürfte eine der
längsten hitzewellen seit jahrzehnten
werden und die flammen sie forderten
jetzt auch ihr erstes todesopfer in der
ortschaft motor sa in portugal da kam
eine frau uns
gelassen darauf quälende hitze und
überall flammen sie kommen immer näher
in den urlaubsregionen in portugal und
in kroatien wüten waldbrände und halten
die rettungskräfte in atem dabei rückt
das feuer entfernen und den bewohnten
gegenden bedrohlich nahe so wie hier in
der portugiesischen region an die
menschen flüchten in panik aus den
häusern werden von den behörden nicht
akut durch die brennende gefährdete
region evakuiert rettungskräfte
feuerwehren katastrophen und zivilschutz
sind im dauereinsatz bekämpfen die
flammen auch aus der luft
und auch in kroatien verfärbt sich der
himmel durch die waldbrände in der
umgebung orange ich darauf liegt in der
luft die menschen flüchten vor den
flammen ans ufer um sich notfalls ins
wasser retten zu können wenn wir hier
rauskommen
insgesamt wählten in südeuropa mehr als
20 brände und das inmitten der
urlaubssaison
besonders die hitzewelle über spanien
und portugal geht in den nächsten tagen
noch weiter dort werden temperaturen bis
zu 46 grad erwartet es dürfte eine der
längsten hitzewellen seit jahrzehnten
werden und die flamen fordern
mittlerweile auch todesopfer in der
portugiesischen ortschaft motto kommt
eine frau in den flammen ums leben auf
der griechischen urlaubsinsel samos
stützt einen löschhubschrauber ins meer
von den vier crew mitgliedern können nun
zwei lebend geborgen werden
rang
[Musik]
und wir schauen wir mal auf unsere karte
von europa wo diese brandherde momentan
eigentlich überall liegen also in
frankreich sogar im norden des landes
dort brennt es in italien in spanien in
portugal und auch ganz recht sehen wir
kroatien und dann schalten wir jetzt
nämlich zu markus leitner der ist gerade
mit seiner familie im urlaub in kroatien
und jetzt in diesen minuten auf der
flucht vor den flammen herr leischner
wie dramatisch ist die situation
ja also es ist so dass es gestern mittag
einem normalen lokal brand gekommen ist
der für uns eigentlich weiter nicht
ungewöhnlich ist dass zu dieser
jahreszeit
ja oft sehr trocken ist und die in
zagreb stationieren wasserflugzeuge
werden der sache auch meistens her
deshalb auch für unsere kinder immer
wieder spannend zu sehen wenn die bei
uns in der buch herunter gegangen sind
um ihre wassertanks wieder zu füllen nur
dieses jahr war es eben halt komplett
anders wir sind gestern mittag wieder
um 12 uhr von dem strand zurück zu
unserer wohnung um einfach wie gesagt
eine siesta abzuhalten die
mittagstemperaturen sind einfach
unerträglich dann dann haben wir einen
lokalen brand bemerkt dem weiter nicht
weiter aufmerksamkeit geschenkt haben
dann ein zwei stunden abgewartet um
wieder an den strand zu gehen dort dann
liegend haben wir dann gemerkt eine
stunde später dass der brand auch so
massiv wurde dass ganz viele rußpartikel
niederschlugen auf unsere strandmatten
profil meine frau mich bat die sachen
zusammenzupacken
weil wir eben halt gedacht haben dass
wir unsere unterkunft die fenster noch
offen haben sind dann also zurück zu
unserer wohnung und haben unsere freunde
getroffen habe das hinter der bergregion
halt gebannt der brand dehnte sich immer
weiter aus wenn wir dann mit unseren
freunden sprachen die also kroaten sind
schaut mal das feuer wird immer größer
die versucht uns zu beruhigen sagt nein
die kennt das doch das kommt nicht
hierhin und das ist doch immer so dass
ja aber du weißt doch ich bin
feuerwehrmann und das sieht schon sehr
massiv aus natürlich dass das doch ihr
rüber kommt gerne auch ostwind nein
beruhigte sie uns wieder keinen fall
dann viel auf einmal der strom aus
wohin ich ja noch mal bat doch sachen
zusammenzupacken dass wir endlich
die örtlichkeit verlassen weil ich eben
uns in gefahr sah da war mir aber noch
nicht klar wie sehr
wir haben dann unsere sachen gepackt wie
ausweise also in das nötigste
telefon etc sind dann aus lohr unter und
dann sagen also schon auf der anderen
seite dass das vorher die ersten häuser
an der bergregion erreicht hatte die zu
uns zeigten und ja und nicht ganze
minute später war das feuer schon quasi
bei uns auf der anderen straßenseite es
sind anwohner mit autos hupender weise
durch die ortschaft grad um andere
anwohner zu bahnen haben die die
einwohner aufgenommen wir sind alle zum
stand befürchtet der brandrauch wurde
dann wirklich so massiv dass die ganze
sonne verdunkelt wurde es war quasi wie
in der nacht
der brandrauch war ja nicht zu ertragen
die die einwohner und touristen haben
sich handtücher nass gemacht im wasser
um überhaupt weiter atmen zu können oder
man hat sich fb2 masken aufgesetzt wenn
man sie im auto hatte
wenn die ganze region war in einem rauch
mantel gehüllt man konnte auch nicht
mehr sehen wo es brennt weil er wirklich
alles nach plan
dann kamen zu den wasserflugzeugen noch
weitere wasserflugzeuge als wandern ins
gebiet insgesamt vier die immer wieder
runter gehen bei uns nabu wieder
auftanken an wasser um wieder weiter
luftangriffe zu fliegen
wie gesagt ich bin aus den beruf und bin
glücklich so überrascht und der
geschwindigkeit wie sich das
ausgebreitet hat nur massiv
die einwohner haben dann mit touristen
zusammen ihren jungs gemacht und sind
dann zu uns rüber gefahren um uns da
wegzuholen also ich war ganz dramatisch
unsere kinder sind von dem ganzen
ereignis so schwer betroffen das nie ja
sie haben geweint ja sie sind
ja so sprachlos darüber dass von jetzt
auf gleich wirklich alles zu ende sein
alles und man steht machtlos dagegen
über ist haben einwohner versucht mit
wasserschläuchen also gardena anschluss
ihr hab und gut zu schützen
natürlich sagen das ist natürlich für
die katz das war wie haben sie alle in
gefahr gebracht
heute morgen sind wir
aufgewacht es liegt immer noch ein
dichter rauch teppich über dem tal
ganz viele glutnester noch andere gegen
der brände weiterhin deswegen immer noch
lust nicht nur zeuge und sind auf der
autobahn ganz viele
löschfahrzeuge entgegengekommen ich
brauche sie werden aus dem gesamten
umland zusammengezogen also das ding ist
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen also die
haben ganz viele noch an arbeitslose das
ist die ganze vegetation ist
ausgetrocknet der wind hat natürlich
dafür gesorgt dass über
soeben das feuer ausgebreitet ist aber
auf der anderen seite war es auch gut
der wind hat das feuer also so schnell
vorangetrieben das also bei der heutigen
betrachtung der ocha
hat sich eigentlich mit viel größerem
schaden ja gerechnet es sind wirklich 35
häuser wirklich abgebrannt aber der
großteil der häuser ist eben halt was
schon bei das feuer mit einer höheren
geschwindigkeit dadurch gerauscht ist
und also ich kann es eigentlich gar
nicht verstehen dass wir da so heil
rausgekommen sind also unser glück war
dass wir wirklich mit den einwohnern an
die strandpromenade geflüchtet sind und
in wasserleben erleichtert zum liste
sind sie mit ihrer familie heil
rausgekommen vielen dank dass sie ihre
eindrücke hier bei uns geschildert haben
und dass wir uns diese bilder
mitgebracht haben wir wünschen ihnen
alles gute eine gute heimreise für sie
und ihre familie
vielen dank